що власне для чого
шановні українці Я думаю
ви пам'ятаєте як у серпні 22-го року
мене було обріхано велика купом бруду
відносно якихось там так званих фотоферм
і через певний проміжок часу я вирішив
завітати в СБУ Службу безпеки України
тому що тоді це відбулося з посиланням
на службу безпеки
я вирішив завітати і спитати як іде
розслідування чи знайшли ці так звані
бутаферми якщо знайшли то кому вони
належать бо все те як Якось Тихо Що в
мене така підозра що ті ботоферми
належить як у президенти
Яке ж було моє здивування коли від
керівника головного слідчого управління
служби безпеки України
Андрія Шевченка я почув що головне
слідчого управління немає до цього
жодного відношення і такого
розслідування не веде Ну чесно кажучи це
взагалі тепер мені здається на таку
інформаційну спецоперацію яка була
задіяна проти опозиції
ви знаєте зараз іде війна і ми чітко
розуміємо в нас один ворон - це крем
Російська Федерація яка вбиває українців
яка намагається захопити нашу Землю І ми
маємо всі тримати єдність для того щоб
дати відпор цьому ворогу опозиція цю
єдність але на жаль з боку влади атаки
на опозиції продовжуються постійно Ну
чесно кажучи що стосується мені мені не
звикати
хочу нагадати як
пан Зеленський наприклад
розпочав скандал відносно
присвоєння мені дипломатичного ранку
і тоді Всі казали що це незаконно це
неправильно цього не можна робити»
але все було
зроблено настільки грубо ця фашивка
настільки грубо була скліпана що вона
часто краще розсипалася ще бистріше
зараз усе з декларація
мені нема за що виправдовуватись це було
то політики за законно зароблені гроші і
без порушень і
більше року тому я все це детально
пояснив назк і Набу про це прекрасно
відомо
а їм між іншим Вітаю набу вони героїчно
знайшли такі мій офіційний
задекларований рахунок в українському
банку ну виявляється все ж таки вони мої
декларацію читали
але якщо серйозно Я хотів сказати про
дві речі
На жаль сьогодні діяльність
правоохоронних органів ми бачимо у
багатьох моментах підміну поняття
замість реальної боротьби з корупцією
вони займаються бурхливою імітацією
діяльності і замість прав які пов'язані
з корупцією які повернуть країні гроші
вони займаються тим щодо корупції немає
жодного відношення Ну як в моєму випадку
А у цей час от Скажіть будь ласка ви
бачили лише підозри ключовим фігурантам
розкрадання мільярдів гривень з
ПриватБанку Я не бачу
їх немає а Чи бачили ви підозри ключовим
фігурантам за розкрадання гуманітарки
Запоріжжя яка розкрадалася космічними
темпами і в той час ключові цього рамки
за повідомлення журналістів спокійно
відпочивають на курортах
а Чи бачили ви підозри за велике
кредівництво в Дніпрі коли
фітнес-тренери на так званому
будівництву доріг освоюють мільярди
гривень це в той час коли країна воює
люди останню гривню віддають на
українську армію на Українські збройні
сили
відміна понять На жаль відбувається і
друге - це подвійні стандарти
хоча би нагадати що пан Зеленський мав
чи має
15 кімнатну ВІЛу в Італії проти дельмар
вартістю більше 100 мільйонів гривень
він надав пояснення назк і це стихло всі
про це забули а тут вони розбивають каву
знаєте хотів би звернутися до
правоохоронних органів сьогодні з
ворогом треба битися і битися з Реальної
корупцією анімітувати діяльність